la domanda che ho ricevuto di più nella
mia vita a parte quanto guadagno
evidentemente adesso è nuova ed è ma
dove sei finito negli ultimi due mesi
non ho pubblicato niente molti pensavano
che avessi abbandonato youtube ho
ricevuto un sacco di messaggi e di
questo li ringrazio
non ho abbandonato youtube per fortuna
degli haters ho intenzione di smettere
con il gameplay questo ragazzi perché
ormai io sono diventato grande e
credibile sono maggiorenne scoperto ieri
e quindi non mi posso più permettere di
portare gli stessi contenuti devo
maturare anche da questo punto di vista
voglio fare roba nuova parte vale al
fatto che ho cambiato completamente il
logo che adesso è questo arriva una
piccola chicca la mia intro e doppiata
da martina pelli che oltre ad essere una
mia carissima amica che ringrazio e la
doppiatrice di anna baker di aloe e di z
[Musica]
fa dj origine come l'ho riconosciuto uno
strumento un po bene questo perché chi
sono all'altro immagino lo conoscete
tutti
[Musica]
grazie davide per adesso farai parte del
mio canale per sempre siamo legati per
sempre matrimonio sono molto orgoglioso
di questo quindi grazie martina grazie
davide che farete parte dei miei video
adesso ricordate quando facevo i viaggi
in america
ho
[Musica]
intenzione di portare il file è quello
che vi faceva ridere una volta ma in
versione migliore sono tutti i video
speciali quindi non ne può uscire uno al
giorno ne esce uno ogni tanto vorrei
farne un paio a settimana speriamo di
riuscirci
ha tra l'altro vado alle hawaii a san
francisco e las vegas nelle prossime tre
settimane quindi vedrete video anche di
quello tutte le belle notizie ve l'ho
detto ti dico solo un'altra cosa prima
di chiudere che ci tengo a dirvi di
questi due mesi è rimbalzato su tutti i
social questo video che stati ben la
forza di vladimir putin gloria dal
curiosissimo ok solo che è il ruolo che
i bombardiamo crane molte persone molti
di voi mi hanno scritto come hai fatto a
prevedere questa cosa che non è che ho
previsto niente perché comunque questo
tipo di conflitto tra russia e ucraina
esisteva già da tanto tempo non si era
mai arrivati a questo punto drastico
indi per cui chiedo cortesemente se
potreste evitare di riproporre questo
video perché non è un argomento su cui
mi va di scherzare
spero capiate colgo l'occasione appunto
nel mentre che misti che vi sto dicendo
questa cosa per dirvi che se volete dare
una mano insomma ai bambini ucraini che
hanno bisogno di aiuto con save the
children vi lascio il link in
descrizione potete dare una mano però
già fatto per niente questo signore mi
spiace per il video breve ma spero siate
contenti che non sono fuggito e già nei
prossimi due o tre giorni uscirà il
primo video del nuovo fa vj quindi
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio la nutella per avermi
accompagnato in tutti questi anni quando
facevo video adesso sono maturato quindi
passiamo al whisky non scherza non si
tocca se anche scassato tutto e noi come
sempre ci rivediamo ad un prossimo video
bella ragazza